l'appel urgent à tous les pays amis y
est tous les pays frères lancé par le
premier ministre libanais hassan diab
mardi soir a été entendu depuis ce
mercredi l'egypte la russie ou encore le
qatar déclare d'envoyer des hôpitaux de
campagne à beyrouth et les premiers
avions chargés de matériels et de
personnels médicaux
arrivent les uns après les autres comme
celui ci en provenance d'iran trois
appareils français sont déjà arrivés sur
place chargée de ressources pour tenter
de répondre à plusieurs types d'urgence
c'est du matériel déjà pour un terminal
pour secourir donc des médicaments des
intrants médicaux c'est du matériel
technique pour intervenir sur les toits
sur les façades pour sécuriser les
façades pour rechercher des victimes
ensevelies pour les dégager
pour les médicalisé la médicalisation de
l'avant et puis également à du matériel
pour notre autonomie logistique puisque
l'idée c'est d'apporter de l'aide au
pays et pas lui demander de l'aide
donc on est autonome dans l'alimentation
en vivre en hébergement dans des
conditions rustiques ces événements ce
site une émotion planétaire et les
veillées en soutien au peuple libanais
se multiplient à travers le monde
nous sommes ici par solidarité avec
notre peuple libanais bien aimé nous
leur souhaitons de la paix toutes nos
prières vont aux libanais de la part des
personnes assiégée de gaza
les expatriés vivent toujours ses choses
différemment de ceux qui vivent au liban
mais cette fois c'était comme un choc la
destruction et la mort que nous avons vu
les explosions les blessures et les
larmes que nous avons vu à la télévision
nous avons ressenti tout ça avec
beaucoup plus de force l'italie a pour
sa part dépêché une équipe de pompiers
spécialisés dans la capitale libanaise
et les contributions solidaire devrait
continuer à abonder ces prochaines
heures